[Applaudissements]
contraint d'interrompre ces
rassemblements en raison de la pandémie
les contestataires ont repris en février
dernier leur défilé hebdomadaire un
mouvement qui ad'ailleurs survécu aux
restrictions liées à la crise sanitaire
vendredi dernier il appelait à nouveau à
l'unité et dénoncé la répression
il faudrait que le peuple algériens
reviennent vers le irak avec ces femmes
ces hommes et ces familles il faut
démontrer que le irak est encore fort et
qu'il faut continuer pour que ces
revendications se concrétise c'est un
début une initiative pour réunir tous
les algériens et pour dire que nous
sommes devant un irak multiples et
divers mais unis car l'union des
algériens et leur force des mots et des
slogans récurrent lors de ces défilés
protestataires le mouvement né en
février 2019 réclament un changement
radical du système politique
le mouvement contestent l'élection du
président actuel abdelmadjid tebboune
alors que cette crise sociopolitique
dans sa troisième année
certaines voix du irak accuse d'ailleurs
la france de soutenir le président
algérien des slogans anti français sont
ainsi apparus lors d'une manifestation
vendredi dernier alors même que le
mouvement doit se mobiliser à nouveau ce
mardi
volontairement dépourvu de leadership et
de structures partisanes le l'irak reste
vulnérable aux divisions et aux
tentatives de récupération notamment des
islamistes lors des récentes
manifestations de nombreux nouveaux
slogans aux antilles pas des
revendications initiales ont ainsi fait
leur apparition
une tendance dénoncée par le haut
conseil de sécurité algériens alors que
le président algérien a annoncé des
élections législatives le 12 juin
prochain pour répondre à la crise il a
mis en garde contre des risques de
dérapage lors des manifestations qui
selon lui vont à l'encontre de la
démocratie